where's the French man where's he hiding
in his little dungeon chef
hey girl yeah good to see this is MIA
wow I can see two head chef Shawn
Michelle has spent his whole life
cooking in high-end French restaurants
but a decade ago he turned his back on
the world of exclusive port cuisine dope
in his own restaurants serving
no-nonsense no-frills French rustic fare
that remain definitely the style of
cooking I wanted to do was totally
different there's nothing to do with
what's being done actually in restaurant
nowadays that's the come from here from
the hardiness treant I'm not cooking for
kings I'm cooking for Papa I'll give a
simple guys like me for country boys
Jean Michelle and sous chef Johnny
server favors like delicious pan-fried
scallops The Bistro classic twice-baked
rock for souffle and rabbit rillette
this award-winning Bistro has earned its
loyal following texture that delicious
lemony you walk through the door of the
gallery you really feel like you're back
in France and that's one of the biggest
compliments I can pay a Frenchman is the
girl with food this good
combined with Jean Michels bonhomie
Shirley my coach diner can't fail to be
seduced you can do it
lead the kitchen drive the kitchen yeah
run the dining room give some French
charm to the service some of the guess
will come in and think that the rabbit
is a little bit intimidating explain
show me shots in love with Lipan and he
adores rabbit and more portly sell it
more shots
Breschel manager Julie and are all
French front-of-house team wastes no
time in Lane on the charm onions and
cheese pie mix it up for you thank you
how does the menu sounds if you have any
question about us or why beats is a cook
okay some how to rub it 1 meringue 1
brioche orders are starting come in
thick and fast Julie the team have done
a great job of selling the rabbit have 6
yes a phrase one happy happy jean-michel
and Julie have a unique system of
communicating service just by what we do
when that band she comes when you bang
she comes sounds like a movie house
everywhere Julie the atmosphere upstairs
is buzzy and relaxed and my diners love
the food
Kurt but the kitchen is far too relaxed
from I like him and there are some silly
mistakes occurring so Michelle is that
hot enough to get it down top Cinnabon
like Jeff
you know that one fish to learn a rabbit
then another er the rabbits flying out
like oh let's go put us to see on our
miniature the most popular dish tonight
is the saddle of rabbit with black
pudding and apple
the meats wrapped in fat to base the
rabbit as it cooks it's great to see
John Michell using such a traditional
technique but I'm worried about how he's
running his kitchen